I guess it's my turn to choose a card
let's see hmm what's really going on and
don't hug me I'm scared yes if only
there was some way to learn more
information about this I'm a computer
I'm a computer ego I got some theories
in line that just bite through your
mouth
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where we watch our internet videos a
quarter frame at a time you think I'm
joking but when it comes to don't hug me
I'm scared it's pretty accurate these
videos are so densely packed with detail
and symbolism that you can watch them
over and over and over again and still
come up with new easter eggs you've
never seen before just look at this one
scene at the end of the third episode of
don't hug me the first time you watch
you might see Roy yellow guy's dad
standing there while his son isn't
doctrine Aidid into the cult of Malcolm
keep looking and you'll notice the
notepad and clock from the prior two
episodes standing there behind him
dressed in white robes keep searching
and you see red guy and duck there too
when they're supposed to be at their
delicious chicken picnic unaware of
where yellow guy even is we're about
here in episode 5 where duck quits the
show there are a few frames of red guys
spaghetti head in the microwave and a
few frames later his legs where the meat
man was standing just seconds before it
isn't just limited to the videos at the
end of episode 5 we see red guy leaving
a phone booth Google search for the
phone number on that phone booth and you
find this hidden video
sar those duck boats the smoking gun
that decode everything that's going on
in the series
no no they aren't but you can bet I took
it all into account in my creation of
today's theory because last time we
covered the easy stuff the symbolism of
the story and how it represents the
children's television show corrupted by
the influence of advertising but today
instead of looking at what don't hug me
i'm scared means in our worries we're
going to explain what it means in its
own world who are these characters what
is the deal with all these Easter eggs
and how should we be interpreting the
ending is it even an ending at all I've
got the answers all here for you and by
the end of this video I guaranteed a
view digital dancing now as I watched
and re-watched the series even though
red guy yellow guy and duck are the ones
who appear on camera most often these
videos seem to have two main characters
red guy yes and Roy yellow guys porn
surfing father and that's reinforced in
Episode six where the whole ending
sequence of events revolves around the
relationship between these two but who
are they
additionally in a series full of bizarre
moments two events seem to be the most
game-changing red guys literal mind blow
at the end of the computer episode and
the dramatic shift to real life in the
middle of episode six who is my theory
that if we could somehow answer who
those two characters are and what those
two events stood for then this whole
enigma ball would unravel so I started
with the guy that we have the most
information about red guy now as we
established last time don't hug me
depicts a television show with red guy
yellow guy and duck as performers on the
series oh there you are we've been
looking for you all afternoon don't get
me wrong I didn't say that they're good
performers but they are performers
nonetheless in addition to all the
camera and set imagery we discussed last
time there are multiple instances where
things don't go as planned and red guy
literally breaks the fourth wall to
address what seems like someone behind
the camera the first instance of this
occurs in Episode two when the clock
begins to talk red guy turns to the
camera genuinely confused saying quietly
who'sa then again at the beginning of
episode four the red guy delivers his
setup if only there was a way to learn
more about the world then strongly
indicates towards the globe even the
music cue follows in duck then joins in
trying to cue the reveal of the globe
but both are genuinely caught off guard
by the computer coming to life
apparently a change in the script that
neither were made aware of it's made
especially clear that red guy wasn't in
on this change when he reveals that they
already had another computer a cute
laptop but is once again cut off before
he can get through his thoughts from
there red guy tries to shut the computer
up by saying things like wait a sec
what's your favorite cooked meat like
beef do that before touching the
computer and causing it to freak out so
clearly red guy is both unaware of and
very displeased by these unexpected
changes so then who is he well that
answer comes to us in the final episode
dreams
it starts with yellow guy left alone
learning about dreams from the lamb but
quickly transitions to red guy IRL at a
desk job and singing the creativity song
at a karaoke bar to receive let's just
say less than stellar reviews now most
other theories see this as occurring in
the present day but what makes more
sense is that this scene is actually a
flashback to the red guy's life before
the show when he was working at a boring
desk job and had dreams of making a
children's television program I mean
look at the way he pitches the idea of
the singing file to his boss something
that becomes physically manifested later
in the video
more on that minute but truly despite
the monotone voice this guy is a guy
with dreams dreams that
sometimes seem like they're getting
drown in a pool of oil or booed off
stage with all the enthusiasm of a
youtube comment section but within that
sea of bored disapproval one person
watching the red guy's performance
wasn't booing ROI and it's here that we
finally learn of the secret to their
relationship
Roy discovered red guy at an open mic
night and made him a deal to sponsor the
kids show that red guy had always wanted
but then how do we know that Roy is the
sponsor it's easy
we're expressly told it in the credits
episodes two through six of dhm is end
with a special thank you to all the
Kickstarter backers and the last person
thanked in every episode is Roy because
he too is a financial backer in fact
within the lore of the series he's the
main backer a sponsor with greedy
motives who gets out of hand once red
guy is out of the picture in episode 5
we see very clearly in the healthy
eating episode that Roy sells food
products
his name is littered everywhere but more
specifically notice the foods his name
is on Roy's flower
Roy's health juice Roy's oats and Roy's
flakes
most of these are grain based now
compare that to what the meat in the can
are teaching the children as healthy all
foods that are grain or dairy based and
also aspect but this theme of
questionable health benefits behind
plain foods doesn't stop there it also
appears in a bizarre interview the
characters did with the British website
it's nice that in May of 2016 in it red
guy says that he's trying in all plain
foods diets and that it's causing some
disturbing side effects wonder if his
teeth are turning gray in fact Roy's
role as a food producer can even tie in
with the overalls that he and a son wear
this isn't the first time that we've
seen some product placement in these
episodes in episode 4 the computer
prints out a picture of oat cereal and
then also shows them a picture of the
same cereal in the newspaper if you look
really closely you can even see the oats
digital dancing considering the theory
that red guy is the creator and Roy is
the sponsor this product placement was
probably a big point of contention but
with red guy no longer on the show as of
episode 5 Roy was free to fill the video
with his many products and skewed health
messages as he wanted to turning it from
being educational to being one big
commercial you can even see it happen if
you check out the final moments of
episode 4 frame by frame you see both
duck and yellow guy glitch into the
picture but look closely and you'll see
that their brains are exposed a sign
that they've been brainwashed by the
computer so if Roy's the sponsor then
what's the deal with yellow guy calling
him his dad
well he's not lying as sponsor of the
show Roy can make sure that his son is
put into the spotlight this would
explain why yellow guy is clearly the
most inexperienced of the three on
camera but don't think for a second that
Roy is some stage mom trying to get his
son famous fight the contrary pulling
back to that it's nice that interview we
actually hear Roy speak for the only
time ever throughout the entire series
when asked if he had anything to say he
responds with the following my silly boy
has allowed his eyes to grow arrogant
and rude for this I will take him on a
trip to punish land he hikes punish land
something tells me this isn't Disney
world's latest park extension but when
you look at the series it actually makes
a lot of sense yellow guy has been the
victim from the very beginning in
episode 1 his painting is destroyed and
he's told that his favorite color isn't
creative in episode 2 the clock yells at
him until his ears bleed in episode 3
he's nearly seduced into joining a cult
in Episode four he gets brainwashed by
the computer in Episode five he pulls a
Scott tenorman and eats his friend and
then in episode six is tortured by an
unending barrage of a name lessons oh
yeah and also drowns and oil but if you
think Roy's punished land stops there
well boy howdy you are wrong observant
viewers will spot horses sprinkled all
over dhm is videos pictures of horses
rocking horses horse figurine animated
horses well in the same interview with
it's nice that it's revealed that yellow
guy is scared of horses he's also
apparently allergic to eggs wasps crabs
meat and trees all of which are elements
that we see worked into various episodes
throughout the series Roy's not only
sponsoring the series to push his own
goods he's also doing it to push his son
to the brink of insanity even don't hug
me I'm scared most famous Easter Egg
fits in with the idea of Roy teaching
yellow guy
lesson the unchanging date of June 19th
has bothered would-be theorists since
the second episode but we have our
answer right now June nineteen nineteen
fifty-five the date which we see hinted
at over and over again throughout the
series was Father's Day in 2011 when the
first episode of don't hug me I'm scared
was released Father's Day was also on
June 19th and this year the date of
release for the very last episode was
June 19th which lo and behold was once
again Father's Day
Roy is punishing his son for letting his
eyes grow arrogant and rude maybe
something about catching his dad
watching porn but regardless he forces
him to respect his authority by making
every day Father's Day a constant
reminder of who is in charge as long as
the date is June 19th yellow guy is
doomed to suffer this torture with no
end in sight or at least that's what
would have happened if not for red guy
which means it's finally time to talk
about the ending at the end of episode 4
red guy resists being lured into Roy's
computer world leaving the living room
set with Roy hidden in the corner and
instead noticing that the computer is
hooked up to a mysterious red cable
leading to the next room when he opens
the door it's revealed that he's covered
in motion-tracking balls and discovers a
super low-tech version of episode 1
being recorded then his head explodes so
what does all this mean well the head
explosion is definitely a literal
version of red guy's mind being blown
but what exactly blue is mined in the
first place
many have said it's him realizing that
he's on a TV show but as we've seen
already both he and Doc break the fourth
wall repeatedly meaning they know
they're on camera instead I think the
revelation is a lot more positive notice
that he follows a red cable hooked up to
the computer and that he's leaving Roy's
room a room mind you with higher
production value filled with props and
motion capture ability only to find
himself in a room with a crude set and
props red guy's mind blow in this moment
is that he doesn't need the dominating
presence of Roy that he can create his
series on a low budget and load it
directly onto the computer ie a place
like YouTube without needing a bunch of
money remember episode 4 is all about
what you can do on a computer according
to Roy it's all superficial consumer is
some things charts digital style dancing
but here red guy sees a video being
filmed and uploaded directly to a
computer and again based on what we
discussed last video this is similar to
the journey the creators of dhm is
taught to keep their series independence
so red guy leaves roy series and then in
episode 5 we repeatedly see imagery of
him on the outside looking in he's
looking at the series from a new
outsider's perspective those were
boating phone calls for duck drought the
episode are coming from him we see him
exiting a phone booth at the end of the
episode for crying out loud
it's him calling his friends to let them
know that there's another option that
they can and need to escape to stop
selling their souls to Roy duck answers
and tries to get away but as we see is
captured canned and consumed but as duck
getting eaten literals hard to say it
seems like it shouldn't be right but
then again Roy is a farmer and duck is
the only character who happens to be an
animal the can consuming the duck could
be the duck getting canned hmm
all of this comes to a head in episode 6
yellow guy is the last one standing on
the show held there by his father once
the episode gets underway we see the
origins of the series with red guy being
discovered by Roy at karaoke we then cut
to red guy discovering for lack of a
better term the show machine which
creates the characters and situations
that we've seen throughout the previous
five episodes now mind you none of this
is literal it's all meant to be symbolic
this is red guy coming to grips with the
show he created
for the first time ever with clear eyes
the effect it's having on kids like
yellow guy Roy discovers red guy trying
to shut down the Machine and reaches his
hand out to touch the red guy on the
shoulder it's not a gesture of
aggression it's more like a peace
offering an invitation to come back and
work for the show once again because
face it
what else does red guy have in a society
full of negativity towards his ideas Roy
was the only one willing to take a
chance on it and you see that's the
brilliance of episode 6 here it starts
by addressing typical dreams the ones
that happen at night but when you look
again it's actually about personal
dreams and how seeing a dream achieved
like red guy finally creating the show
he always wanted can turn into a waking
nightmare but it's at that moment that
red guy decides to literally and
figuratively pull the plug on both the
show and his relationship with Roy eager
to see what will happen next and it
works we restart the series but with
some very important differences all the
characters are now the color they said
was their favorite in episode 1 blue red
and green the date on the calendar
changes from June 19th to June 20th
meaning that it's no longer Father's Day
and Roy has no influence on the show
anymore it is quite literally the start
of a new day and that also makes sense
when you look at the sets at the
beginning of episode 1 the kitchen is
full of props like knives and plates and
books and a telephone but the reset
version at the end of episode 6 is very
simple with just a table and a few other
items without Roy's sponsorship they're
working on a smaller budget but the
characters are finally free the notepad
flips open and the first episode begins
again but this time it's on their own
terms
this time Green will be a creative color
but hey that's just a theory of film
theory
and gods at least that's my
interpretation and at the heart of it
don't hug me I'm scared is all about
creativity and interpretation I've seen
other theories that are way different
from this one that I've laid out for you
but they all still deserve your respect
and attention after all when asked by
the UK news site Metro about fan
theories for don't hug me I'm scared
co-creator Becky Sloane said quote we've
read a lot of theories online about what
it all means and they are all correct so
go watch the show again look for your
own Easter eggs come up with your own
theory and leave it in the comments
below there's only one rule though guys
be creative and with that we leave
behind D HMIS as we close the book on
this two-parter I gotta ask over the six
episodes have don't hug me which was
your favorite one creativity time love
computers healthy eating for dreams
click on one to choose I'm really
curious which one you responded to most
I'm a toss-up between creativity and
computers the loved one was good too I'm
just glad to be done with this I've been
watching these videos over and over and
over again and most of the time it's at
like midnight or 1:00 in the morning
these are not things that you want to
watch a bunch of times before you go to
bed trust me no really
trust me anyway click on one to choose
and cast your vote can't wait to see
what the results are now if you'll
excuse me I'm going through some
superhero withdrawals or should I say
supervillain withdrawals